The thing behind how you
build an ad words campaign,
is similar to how you
build any campaign.
Just remember to understand
your user and target audience.
Explore different key words and
different messaging and
keep iterating and
optimizing until you see your desired.
Results.
Now, Ad words can be a bit expensive
when you're new and starting out,
because it's a popular tool and
competition can be high.
But, people keep searching and
they keep paying attention to the top
paid result, so it's worth optimizing.
But don't worry.
There are other options you can explore.
You can try looking for
younger channels,
like paid ads on YouTube or Instagram.
Or you can even explore
completely untapped platforms and
find new opportunities for growth.